tears of the kingdom is a massive game
and like breath of the wild after the
tutorial area you can head off in any
direction which can be overwhelming and
there are extra things you can miss
we're here to help you navigate the
starting area and get you ready for
exploring Hyrule worry free just keep in
mind this covers the first two to three
hours of the game so early game spoiler
warning here for tears of the Kingdom
after the beginning scripted section
where you can't really deviate from the
path you're plopped down in the great
Sky Islands you're going to want to
first pick up the broken Master Sword
push the switch to open the door and
make your way through the tunnels this
decayed Master Sword has very low
durability and if it breaks it doesn't
recharge but it's not a huge deal you
will pick up other equipment very soon
right before seeing the outside world
there's a treasure chest with a piece of
armor inside waiting for you here and
it's easy to overlook since the starting
area enemies aren't pushovers having
extra armor reduces damage taken from
half a heart to quarter heart and you
won't need to use as many healing items
so don't miss it then head out into the
great Sky Island's main area diving into
the large pond below get yourself
acclimated to the controls and explore
this small island for a couple tree
branches and mushrooms if you beat the
construct on the left down the stairs
you can NAB its more powerful wooden
stick on the altar behind it head over
to the right and grab the Pura pad from
the steward construct look around for
more loot then go out to the platform
and dive off into the pond below
[Music]
from here you can explore the immediate
area for a bit scrounging materials
clicking and getting yourself acclimated
to combat if you'd like the end goal
though is to approach the Temple of time
so after you've gotten your fill of
exploring this area you can run from or
take out the guard with the shield and
go ahead and approach the main building
after a short cut scene raru will punch
you in the right direction towards your
very first shrine but let's first
explain the layout of what's happening
now while the multiple islands and land
formations can be disorienting your path
right now is a counterclockwise trip to
several shrines around the island going
higher and higher unlike the great
plateau and breath of the wild which
allowed shrines to be completed in any
order there are going to be several
optional side areas along the way that
you're welcome to explore and loot as
well but we'll be focusing on the main
path and getting you finished on the
great Sky Island just remember
everything here can be easily Revisited
later with better traversal options so
there's no massive rush to figure out
this entire Island if you'd rather
progress the story go ahead and head to
the first shrine on the right and take
out this Archer to get your first bow
cross the river climb up the Rock and
enter uku shrine
once you've entered to the shrine you'll
receive the ultra hand ability builds
the bridges and platforms to complete
the challenge or just figure out your
own way to complete it after coming back
out either on the right side Ultra hand
a bridge together or on the left side
ride the railing over to the other side
I recommend nabbing the stone ax that's
next to the construct as access to cut
down trees whenever you want is nice to
have right now again at any point along
the way here you're welcome to explore
around cook and play with things in the
environment you'll want to make your way
down to the lodge Pond to continue on
and here you can find a bunch of logs
and a sale perfect for building a boat
go ahead and use your new Ultra hands to
lift and piece together your boat and
sail across to the other side
from here head up the hill and into the
next Shrine in Issa Shrine this is where
you'll learn the next ability fuse this
allows link to attach various materials
and equipment to your weapon so go ahead
and fuse your sword or Shield then go
ahead and Parry through the rubble by
holding ZL and pressing a or knock it
down with your fused Boulder sword to
the right there's a bow and fire fruit
all around draw your bow fuse the fire
Fruit by pressing d-pad up then shoot
the dry Vines to get your key
unlock the door and head to the next
room where you'll need to up your combat
prowess there's extra equipment to fuse
on both right and left sides of you the
spikes on the left provide the biggest
attack boost when fused but to beat this
enemy easily try to light the dry Tinder
around it and don't burn yourself in the
process once you beat the construct
you're good to go and head out of the
shrine once you head out you'll be given
your signature energy cell belt which
can be used to power zonai devices from
here head down the stairs and to the
right there will be constructs to beat
but also a ton of options to fuse with
so go ahead and experiment with whatever
you'd like keep heading east through the
enemies and into the cavern called
pondside cave and make your way through
the tunnels in here there's a bunch of
materials to collect and pesky Keys make
sure you have some rock or Bowl diffused
weapons to destroy the black oars you'll
also come across your first bubble frog
these frogs don't do any damage but have
Bubble gem rewards you will will need
later in the game so go ahead and try to
shoot its head if you can and defeat it
so you can free the little bloopy inside
it near the end of the cave don't miss
the chest on the left side the archaic
tunic to complete your outfit and get a
bit more defense once you're outside
again this will be a similar situation
to before where you have a large lake to
Traverse and some parts to build with
ultra hand used logs and fans to build
yourself a boat the most important thing
while building is that it must be
symmetrical since it's designed off of
real world physics things that are not
even will cause the boat to tilt in odd
directions so make sure you keep the
boat even before you take off hit the
boat with your weapon to engage the
engine and Float on over to the other
side
when you make it go ahead and make your
way up the staircase the main goal is to
go south up the hill and find a dark
Cavern here you can build your first
Minecart attach the fan onto the card
and make your way inside the mining cave
[Music]
since it gets dark you'll have to use
bright Bloom seeds you can use your bow
to fuse and shoot them but that takes up
durability and arrows the best way is to
throw them hold art ready to throw hold
d-pad up to find the bright blue then
release the d-pad to ready to throw and
release it you'll eventually find the
forge with Steward constructs working
you can open their shop but right now
it's not entirely recommended to
purchase any of these items the zonai
charges can be good if you need more
currency for machine parts later from
the gumball machine but the crystallized
charge is expensive and doesn't provide
benefits right now so it's recommended
to skip head toward the Cave opening and
grab the three fans next to the
construct take the card over to the
tracks and then open the menu and drop a
fan you just got and attach it this will
take you to the next area above you this
area can be explored a bit including the
gashapon machine directly in front of
you which will take zonai charges you
may have collected so far I recommend
you pull once or twice to get some extra
machine parts to build with later the
fans and portable pot should be
self-explanatory but you can also get
flame emitters which can be attached to
Shields or weapons to spit Flames at
enemies make your way East towards a
small cave but make sure to grab the
spicy pepper outside the cave opening
before you head in and grab more inside
these are used to cook cold resistant
dishes which you will need cook them up
in the stove at the front I recommend
making two to three meals worth of spicy
peppers then head up the pit cave
tunnels to the left once you reach the
top opening you'll be greeted by a
bitter cold breeze go ahead and pop that
cold resistant meal Make Your Way North
East and you may see a Cave opening and
construct in battle with choo choos head
into the cave and head up the slope you
may run into like likes which are weak
to fire either use fire fruits or your
flame are meant to open their weak spots
and give it a good whacking
when you get out side again wrap around
and head uphill going north you'll end
up in a Grove with trees and axes if
needed fuse the stones to weapons you
have or any sharp weapons and cut down
three to four trees Ultra hand them
together and build a ladder and turn it
into the groove of the icy Hillside you
see in front of you walk to your left
and you've got your third Shrine
gutenbach Shrine you'll now get your
third ability Ascend this is a fairly
straightforward ability letting you rise
through solid matter above you just
Ascend through the outcrops on the wall
in front of you cut down the ropes to
the bridge then Ascend it to reach the
top Ascend through the final platforms
and make your way to the goal now that
you have Ascend head underneath the
wooden platform in front of you and to
send through it to reach the next area
inside the tree in front of you you can
NAB the Nifty archaic warm Greaves
letting you freely explore in the cold
without using meals now you can add some
more parts from the gotcha machine on
your upper right but your goal now is to
head back to the Temple of Time using
the run way you see on your left go
ahead and use the glider and slide it
into the runway to Hitch ride
while you don't have full control of it
you can nudge the glider in different
directions by stepping on different
sides of it if it starts going off
course since you don't have a paraglider
still go ahead and dive into the lake
and swim to Shore and open the Temple of
Time from here the final ability recall
which you can use to Traverse and climb
the moving Wheels in front of you go
ahead and try to open the final door
unfortunately because you need four
Hearts you'll need to do one last Shrine
to open the door do as raru says and
teleport to the room of Awakening you'll
find the revolving Wheels again so
Ascend up the platform to the right of
the wheels and make your way across to
the other side in this chamber you'll
find the final Shrine nachoya Shrine go
ahead and jump on the rafts and use
recoil on them to move forward and make
your way up the waterfall you can NAB
the chest on your left if you want but
to make it through the final door you'll
have to time recall on either clock hand
to make them match the direction of the
other and keep the door open for you
collect your final blessing of light
when you're back outside hustle your way
back to the door you had trouble with
earlier at the Temple of Time talk to
the goddess statue to get your fourth
heart open the door and you're at the
home stretch head along broken Platforms
in front and Ascend when you're
underneath the next portion then
interact with the pedestal to see what
happens to the master sword you are now
finally ready to explore the world below
but you might be asking yourself wait
where's my paraglider while you are
completely free to explore whatever you
want once you have touched Solid Ground
we highly recommend you do a couple more
errands first before you head off onto
your next adventure first follow the
quest marker to the town in front of
Hyrule castle and make your way inside
Lookout Landing the central Hub in tears
of the Kingdom from here you will
initiate lots of important quests so I
recommend getting a lay of the town and
talking to folks to get yourself
situated what you need to do is head to
pura's office at the main entrance and
start the next part of the quest to look
for Captain Haws head straight forward
to the castle and definitely unlock
kionos's Shrine on the right side on the
way there go up the main winding path up
to the first Gatehouse Captain Haws is
actually quite hidden here find him on
the second story of this Gatehouse
outside by climbing or ascending go
ahead and have a chat with him and a
short cutscene will occur once you're
done teleport back to kainos's Shrine
and speak with Pura again she'll now
explain how Skyview Towers work and
start fixing your first one all the sky
view Towers will be unlocked to use and
you'll get your Nifty paraglider once
you go for your first test flight dive
back down to poorer below and she'll set
you up with the waypoints for your main
quest line
after that you're finally ready to
tackle tears of the Kingdom with all the
main tools you'll need the world is
truly your oyster go out talk to people
explore the vast world and defeat the
great evil out there if this video
helped you get your feet on the ground
let us know we will have a slew of
content for tears of the Kingdom so to
keep up with Link's latest Adventure
stay tuned here on Gamespot
foreign
[Music]